ich habe ein sehr persönliches thema
letzten endes mitgebracht ich habe ein
thema es geht um der die ältere
generation ich möchte oder ich stehe
dazu dass wir die ältere generation an
weihnachten nicht alleine lassen sollten
weil wir können ganz ganz viel von ihnen
lernen wollen sie oder sollen sie nicht
im stich lassen und ich glaube einfach
wer geschätzt wird bleibt lebendig ich
habe in den letzten jahren weil ich eben
recht erfolgreiche große social media
kanäle mit meiner oma zusammen habt habe
ich ganz viel zeit mit ihr verbracht und
habe einfach gemerkt das ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir als junge generation
und letzten endes jeder von der älteren
generation ganz ganz viel lernen kann
und
es ihnen auch ganz viel gibt wenn wir
mit ihnen zeit verbringen denn es ist
unglaublich kostbar für sie wir können
ihre alten werte die sie leben und
pflegen können wir wieder vielleicht ein
bisschen aufpolieren und in unsere
heutige zeit mit integrieren und einfach
wieder intensiver leben und ja wir
hatten ja letztes jahr schon mal so ein
bisschen dieses problem dass man nicht
wusste oder ja die die familien einfach
sich an weihnachten nicht gesehen haben
und ich weiß ganz deutlich von meiner
oma dass sie es liebt und wenn wir zeit
verbringen und dass das ganz oft viel
mehr kraft den eltern den menschen gibt
wenn wir wirklich zeit mit ihnen
verbringen und deshalb hoffe ich auch
dass wir wieder an weihnachten dass
jeder bei seiner familie sein kann und
ganz viel zeit mit ihnen verbringt
dieser these widerspricht ja niemand die
ist einfach richtig ich will nur was
ergänzend dazu ich habe das auch mal
einen meiner eigenen familie erlebt
kinder brauchen großeltern aufzuwachsen
ohne großeltern ist für kinder schwierig
großeltern sind ein wesentliches
wie soll ich sagen kulturelles korrektiv
für das elternhaus alles was die eltern
so machen machen großeltern häufig ganz
anders das fängt damit an dass die
anders kochen dass die anders leben dass
die andere möbel in der wohnung stehen
haben dass es da an das riecht als
zuhause das sie natürlich ganz anders
mit kindern umgehen dass sie mehr zeit
für kinder haben richtig dass sie also
sozusagen den kindern mit offenem herzen
entgegentreten im regelfall jedenfalls
deshalb muss man ich betrachte es nicht
aus sicht der alten dass ich nicht
allein gelassen werden ich betrachte es
aus sicht der kinder für die kinder ist
das wichtig auf jeden fall und deshalb
auch für die eltern dieser kinder und
deshalb ist es an weihnachten richtig
wenn man miteinander möglichst in
familien das fest verbringt richtig ich
meine vorne auch angesprochen man hat
die möglichkeit sich zu testen und wenn
man mit 3g dann letzten endes in der
gesellschaft oder auch an weihnachten
umgehen kann und es keine beschränkungen
gibt weil wenn ob es hat fünf personen
in der familie getestet sind oder 10
wenn da jeder geht es dann das geht
leider nicht weil wenn jemand nicht
geimpftes oder nicht genesen kann er
höchstens mit zwei anderen aus einem
haushalt zusammen weihnachten feiern das
ist dann schon mal ziemlich eng was
großeltern angeht und außerdem schade ja
deswegen will ich aus deiner tesa an
bord streichen und zwar das war
weihnachten lass uns das doch arbeitern
also weihnachten ist natürlich eine
wunderbare aufhängen aber das ist ein
bisschen wie weihnachten gehe ich mal in
die kirche und ansonsten bin ich 365
tagen ja da nicht also entweder gegen
die kirche oder nicht sollte diesmal
frühen sind aus der kirche übrigens
schon seit einigen jahren ausgetreten
aber davon jetzt
kann man sich sagen lasst uns das
wortwahl achten darum strand und ich
erlebe dass er gerne weil du hast
natürlich vollkommen recht eclipse an
mein sohn der es 18 monate wenn der mit
martin obert zusammen ist das ist irre
was für sprünge der da macht weil meine
schwiegereltern die wohn hat auch in
berlin ganz anders mit dem umgehen als
meine frau und ich das mache also
großartig wichtig und natürlich sehe ich
auch gerade dann auch meine
schwiegereltern wieder aufblühen auch
wenn es natürlich schön anstrengend ist
ist da drin lassen ich hab dich nämlich
gefreut hast du gerade das angesprochen
muss ich sagen weil letztes jahr wurden
ja sehr viele ältere menschen auch an
weihnachten alleine gelassen aus dem
grund dass man sie schützen wollte die
brust alleingelassen würden sie musste
alleine gelassen werden und du hast ja
glaube ich letztes jahr auch mit seiner
oma und mit seiner oma verbracht jetzt
komme schon nach oben ich war
unglaublich eng mit meiner oma dies ja
zwei diesem 92 jahren gestorben und ich
hätte sie auch an weihnachten nicht
alleine gelassen egal was die regierung
gesagt hatte und dafür kann ich jetzt
auch wieder eine schöne storm gerne
kriegen auf twitter die nehme ich gerne
hin und deswegen fand ich das ganz
berühren dass du auch letzt ist ja auch
bei ihr verbringt er jeden tag sieben
stunden zusammen glaubt nicht dass
irgendwann begriffen dass auch seine
sachen bei ihr machen seine arbeit und
dann isst du mit dem mittag ich finde es
ganz ganz toll da muss dann musst du
aber jetzt noch mal ein paar sätze zu
diesem zu diesem projekt sagen dass man
auch
stunden 7 schon machen letzten endes
alle ganz viel ja die gemeinsame zeit
genießen aber wir machen jeder macht
seine dinge es ist nicht so dass auch
roche ist fränkisch oder was ist
fränkisch genauigkeit aus nürnberg stein
bei nürnberg
und ist es so dass ich einfach einen
tick tock account habe und instagram
account und da habe ich gelernt in
dieser ganzen zeit was wir für von den
großeltern lernen können ja und ich habe
das was er letztendlich ihr bein auch
beschrieben habt als bedingungslose
liebe ja in dem buch auch beschrieben
dass das ein bisschen der unterschied
zwischen den eltern die ja auch die
gewisse verantwortung haben haben die
großeltern auch aber die die die eltern
auch aber die großeltern haben eben
diese bedingungslose liebe weil sie
einfach immer für ihr kind für ihr
enkelkind da sind und können es ein
bisschen anders erziehen als die eltern
also ich habe es ja ein bisschen gelesen
ich weiß ja worum es hier geht das kann
man ein bisschen plastischer beschreiben
oma sitzt auf dem stuhl und streckt
und ja und der und der enkel macht da
irgendwas wir sind füreinander da und
dann
erzählt dann von söder und dann sagt ihr
mann im netz so ernst
markus und
sagte
ich bin schon auch mit blick auf dieses
jahr weihnachten und mit der älteren
bevölkerung also ich kann dem christen
recht geben auch mit seinem buch ist es
unglaublich wichtig dass wir den die
enge verbindung auch mit unseren
großeltern haben ich habe hat nicht
umsonst ingenieurwesen studiert wenn ich
mein opa das war der mit dem ich in der
werkstatt groß geworden bin und mein
vorbild war was beruflicher art sein
sollte dass ich eben autos entwickeln
wollte war meine ursprüngliche langhans
kann ich eigentlich auch zu meinem beruf
zu meinem ursprünglichen beruf später
dann wurde aus dem hobby die
leidenschaft und die führte dann
tatsächlich eine politik der politik
schafft durchaus auch leid
dass an der stelle schon zu sagen aber
ich habe auch schätzen sie noch
glücklich habe auch noch nie oma und ich
finde es wunderbar mit ihr zeit zu
verbringen natürlich jetzt mit meiner
situation nicht mehr so oft aber ich bin
sehr dankbar dass ich sie noch lange
habt denn es sind die werte es sind der
respekt auch die dinge die sie uns an
geschichten mit geben die uns stärker
werden lassen und ich glaube wir sollten
es vor allem ernst nehmen dass viele
ältere menschen aber auch viele
alleinstehende menschen in einsamkeit im
letzten jahr weihnachten verbracht haben
und diese sozialen folgen können wir
heute noch gar nicht abschätzen wie
stark die sie doch sein werden und
welche folgewirkungen daraus noch
folgenden werden wir haben derzeit das
thema einsamkeit angesprochen aber es
gibt hier durch lockdown auch dieses
thema häusliche gewalt und vieles mehr
also ich glaube auch in der debatte muss
die sozialen betrachtungsweisen eine
stärkere rolle spielen im umgang mit
maßnahmen im umgang auch mit
entscheidungen damit wir eben die
menschen die allein stehen sind oder die
menschen dem schon älter sind und
vielleicht auch hier wohlgemerkt auch
letztes weihnachten doch im kreis ihrer
liebsten verbringen wollen und ich finde
es einfach nur total gerührt kürzlich
habe ich auf seinem buch haben sie
ein bisschen näher kennenlernen oder was
haben sie mit dem europa gebaut an den
autos
restaurierte dem auto reagiert ja
repariert oder oldtimer
restauriert aus
der landwirtschaft kommen natürlich
attraktor durften da nicht fehlen beim
live-walk was tatsächlich
geräusche macht was sound gibt es von
dort haben sie den aufgegeben
meine leidenschaft für die politik hat
es wenn sie ein auto repariert haben ist
das hinterher gefahren wenn sie im
bundestag sitzen
und dass sie so aus leidenschaft und
meine autos repariert da war ich im
antriebsbereich für neue mutig das ist
ein spannendes
und erbrechen die leute rekrutiert